SpaceX has completed the last big test
of its crew capsule before it can launch
NASA astronauts from US soil and there
you just saw the trunk jettison again
some really loud cheers here in
Hawthorne California this test is
looking great so far yes sir the
American aerospace manufacturer mimicked
a launch failure off the Florida coast
it was testing whether the capsule could
separate from a rocket and carry the
crew home if something went wrong SpaceX
founder Elon Musk says it was a
picture-perfect mission yeah I'm super
fired up this is great
you know it's really great you know
anyone who has an adventurous bone in
their body is gonna be very excited
about this and I think it will help
really a great interest in space well my
wall is a senior space writer at space
comm and he explains what SpaceX will do
after its crew capsule test there are
only a few more things that they need to
do they yeah like they want to go
through all of the data from this test
flight just to make sure that it that it
was things did go according to plan
which it certainly seems like it did you
know it looked like a picture-perfect
mission but they're gonna like examine
that spacecraft and just make sure
nothing weird happened and then like
they're gonna do a couple more parachute
tests because it's it's like a newly
revamped but yet the parachute system on
the crew dragon so they're just gonna
make sure that everything works just
just the way it seems to be working well
and then that will pretty much clear the
way that's that's why people think I
mean sometime this this spring is is
what NASA said and again also what like
you know I must have said that's that's
when the first crewed flight is probably
going to take place
NASA keeps on saying they don't want to
be the only customer for the spacecraft
they want to be one of like a bunch of
different customers who will take
advantage of this service to get up to
space and get back down again and it's
sort of hopes to be that like anchor
tenant basically or like the driving
force that kind of shows other companies
what they can do with this and sort of
say well yeah that's let's like start a
whole new commercialization kind of
opportunity in space and so yeah I mean
maybe we're going to see these these
sorts of spacecraft I mean crew Dragon
and all
boeing's maybe they're gonna be taking
private space tourists up and down I
mean maybe there they're gonna be doing
a lot of other things or the university
as well will sort of pay them to like
take payloads up there to do experiments
and all I mean that's that's the
long-term vision NASA wants to kind of
jumpstart so they're just hoping that
this is the first step